anyway here with reaction is President
Trump attorney Joe takapina is with us
Joe welcome back glad to uh have you you
know we often talk in this program about
a dual system of justice we often
discuss the fact that equal justice
under the law in my view today is dead
in America equal application of our laws
is dead quick couple of examples want
your your commentary on the events of
this week you know Hillary Clinton that
top secret classified information on her
servers uh we believe that that our
enemy Nations like the Communist Chinese
got access to those servers okay so was
her home rated no uh did James Comey say
no reasonable prosecutor or prosecute
yes he did did she also destroy 33 000
emails and and devices with hammers uh
using bleach bit on the servers and the
hard drives yeah she did that uh Joe
Biden had four separate locations top
secret classified information no rate of
chappaquad no rate at any any of the
Biden homes or locations where these
where these documents were so my
question is uh why is it that Donald
Trump is now getting a pile on of
charges had a full raid they did the
exact same thing that he did and if
their big argument now is that Donald
Trump might have tried to erase
surveillance video how is that any
different from cleaning hard drives with
bleach bit and destroying devices
it's not tronum what you have is what
you and I have been talking about since
January February um whenever I started
making these appearances
um and remember I don't represent
president Trump in the in this
classified documents case but
um I will tell you this what you see
here is what I've been saying a
two-tiered system of justice and it's
it's it's it's it's come live and in
color this week
um you know Donald Trump they continue
to pile on why because he's leading the
polls 52 percent the Republican you know
nomination
um he's beating Joe Biden in the polls
so they think the more they pile on the
more they attack him the the less likely
it is that he's going to become our
president again it's having the opposite
effect because people of this country
are not stupid
um and I think as a whole they're
starting to understand that the
weaponization of the justice system is
in Full Throttle right now you have a
situation where you know I just heard
Greg and and the former uh United States
started talking about
um what happened in the hunter Biden
case that was insane and unprecedented
for a federal judge and I've been before
many of them I I on both sides of that
courtroom and and I will tell you this
for a federal judge to do what she did
um and for that plea to be as
unprecedented as it was where it was
covering crimes blanket immunity for
everything except future crimes that he
may commit which you obviously can't
keep immunity for um which registering
as a foreign agent all those things that
you're way more serious than any
allegation in any of the president
Trump's indictments um it's it shows you
it's a two-tiered system of justice that
is now out of control and this country
is in a bad way right now Sean it's in a
very very bad way you know well I want
to say this last thing the investigative
process is supposed to be pure but what
you have here is an investigative
process that's now turned into election
interference there's no offense or buts
about it the American people should
decide who the next president will be
not a Democrat appointed prosecutor or a
justice department serving at the whim
of the president the people should
decide the next person there's plenty of
time to bring these charges you know
there's five-year statute of limitations
on these cases right
um they didn't have to rush to bring
this all right Joe takapina thank you
when we come back hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else